The 16th most common question asked by
the non-Muslim regarding Islam is why in
Islam a woman inherits
half of that of the male. If you see
history, all these centuries before
women were not allowed to inherit in
most of the religions and even in
European law. It was only in 1800 and in
the 19th century a woman was allowed to
inherit or own property. Islam gave this
right 1400 years ago. There are various
verses in the Quran which talk about
inheritance. Surah Bakra chapter 2 verse
number 140. Surah Bakar chapter number 2
verse number 280
and surah Nisa chapter 4 verse number
7-9. Surah Nisa ch 4 verse number 19.
Surah Nisa ch 4 verse number 33. Surah
Nisa ch 4 verse number 176 and surah
maida 5 verse number 106 to 108. There
are various verses Quran talks about
inheritance. But the major verses of
where it comes to division of
inheritance is surah nisa 4 verse number
11 and 12.
Allah says in surah nisa 4 verse number
11 and 12 that
as for the inheritance of your children
the male gets a share twice the female.
If only females, if two or more, they
share in two/3. If only one female, she
gets half. And the verse continues. As
for your parents, they get one sixth. If
you have children. If there are no
children,
the mother gets one/3. But if there are
brothers and sisters, she gets one
sixth. All this is after giving of the
legatories and debts. That means when
you divide the inheritance, first give
your debt.
Give the debt of the person and any due
that is there and then divide the share.
Verse number 12 continues of surah nisa
chapter 4 as in what your wives leave
for you. You get half the share if there
are children and you get 1/4 the share
if there are children.
In what you leave for your wives, your
wife get 1/4 if there are no children.
She gets 1/8 if there are children.
And if more than one wife, they share in
that 1/4 and 1/8.
And
if you have no ascendants and no
descendants,
your brothers and sister they share.
This is after giving off all the
legacies and debts.
difficult to remember? No need of
remembering everything. You can go home
and check on your app, open the Quran.
Surah Nis is chapter 4 verse number 11
and 12.
I do agree in most of the cases the
woman inherit doubles in that of the
male counterpart. But there are cases in
which the inherent equal. For example,
the mother and father if their children
have children,
the mother and father both inherit one
sixth
if their child dies and if their child
had children if they have grandchildren
alive.
So mother and father form the children
inheritance each gets one six that means
male and female get equal. There are
sometimes female get double.
If a woman dies leaving the husband, no
children and mother and father, husband
gets half, father gets one/3,
mother gets,
father gets one sixth, mother get two
sixth, that is 1/3. If a woman who has
no children dies leaving behind the
husband and parents, the husband gets
half,
father gets 1/6th, mother gets 26th or
1/3 double. But I do agree in most of
the cases
the female gets double the share of the
male. For example,
the male gets a double the share of the
female. For example, the son gets double
than that of the daughter
and the wife and the husband gets double
the share of
the wife.
If there are no children, husband gets
half, wife gets 1/4. If there are
children, husband gets 1/4, wife gets
1/8. In most of the cases is double.
What is the logical reason that Islam
gives double inheritance to the male as
compared to the female? The reason is as
I mentioned earlier in Islam man is the
bread earner. All the financial
responsibility is laid on the shoulders
of the man. The woman is free from
financial obligations.
Before a woman is married, it's the duty
of the father and the brother to look
after lodging, boarding, clothing and
all financial aspect. And after she's
married, it is the duty of the husband
and the son to look after lodging,
boarding, clothing, all financial
aspect. A woman need not work for her
living
willingly. IF SHE OPTIONALLY wants to
do, that's a different case. But no one
can force her to work.
She is financially secured.